Speaker 1: Well, we've finally gotten the results.
Mehmet Oz, the television doctor running in the
Republican primary in Pennsylvania, has won that
Republican primary and will face the Democratic
primary winner, John Fetterman. Dave McCormick,
the candidate with whom Oz was in a virtual tie,
has conceded NPR can now report Dr. Oz
wins the Senate primary in Pennsylvania
after McCormick concedes. Republican Dave
McCormick conceded Friday to celebrity Dr.
Mehmet Oz in Pennsylvania's Senate primary as the
state conducted a recount of the May 17 election,
according to the AP. Oz led McCormick by
972 votes. Final results were expected early
next week. In remarks to supporters on Friday,
McCormick said he could not make up the deficit
in the recount. Today, I called Mehmet Oz to
congratulate him on his victory, said McCormick.
And I told him what I always told you. I will
do my part to try to unite Republicans and
Pennsylvanians behind his candidacy, behind his
nomination for Senate. Of course, Oz was endorsed
by Trump. Oz tweeted, I received a gracious phone
call from David McCormick, and I'm tremendously
grateful for his pledge of support in the fall
election. We share the goal of a brighter future
for Pennsylvania and America. Also relevant. And
as a reminder, we've covered this. Fetterman is
recovering from a stroke he suffered days before
the primary needed to undergo a pacemaker. Implant
procedure has since not returned to the campaign
trail and has only done video appearances since.
David Brody from Real America's Voice, he tweeted
as a result of this, this concession by Dave
McCormick. All hail the all powerful Trump. Not
sure I would be going with the Hail Trump stuff
myself. Last time I saw Hail Trump, it was Richard
Spencer at a white nationalist meeting doing the
Hitler salute and saying, Hail Trump, hail Trump
with people in the crowd doing the same thing.
In terms of the eventual general election race.
There's really no good polling yet in terms of Oz
versus Fetterman, Pennsylvania Senate, Oz versus
Fetterman on Real Clear Politics. They have it
merely as a toss up right now. And in 2016,
the Republican, Pat Toomey, won by 1.6.
In 2010, the Republican Pat Toomey won by two.
This is an open seat now, an open seat. And we
are going to be very strongly supporting John
Fetterman. Now, this is an opportunity to have
a very real conversation about the concentration
of resources. And we dealt with this a little bit
last week on the Friday mailbag. There are endless
races in which any of us could invest time and or
money. Now we want to. You never count anybody
out. You want to support good candidates. But
we also sometimes have to make hard choices when
there are limited resources. And I'm just going
to give you an example and I'm not telling
you what to do, but this is a real question.
Marcus Flowers is the challenger to Marjorie
Taylor GREENE in the Georgia I believe it's the
14th District that GREENE is running in. That's
an outrageously red district. Statistically,
it's very unlikely that Marcus Flowers has a shot.
But you could invest time and money in that race
as a progressive. You also have Fetterman voters
in Pennsylvania. That race could quite literally
decide who controls the Senate starting in January
of 2023. So I never say count anyone out. I never
say don't work on on races that are important
to you. But at a certain point, we also have
to consider that with limited resources with
which race is most likely to make a difference,
an almost certainly unwinnable race against
Marjorie Taylor GREENE in the Georgia 14th,
or the Fetterman versus Osiris in the Pennsylvania
Senate. Well, I think that the the the facts tell
us it's almost certainly the latter. So just
something to keep in mind as we go forward here.